now to tajikistan where the president
has ordered around
20 000 reserve forces to protect the
country's border with afghanistan
the order came after more than a
thousand afghan soldiers abandoned their
posts and fled to tajikistan following
a taliban offensive in the border region
the taliban has been gaining
territory across afghanistan since
international troops
started pulling out leaving many afghans
worried about their futures
these afghan people are determined to
leave the country
that's why thousands of them have
gathered at this passport office in
capital kabul
trying to find a way out
their future has become too uncertain as
the effect of the us troops withdrawal
starts to unfold
most of the districts have fallen
there's not a single district without
fighting
the taliban have even reached the chief
of police's office and provincial
capitals
i've come here to get my passport and
get out of afghanistan
it's not safe here many embassies have
registered a dramatic increase in the
number of visa
and passport applications as the taliban
advances
people fear the hard-won progress over
the past two decades will start to roll
back
women and girls for example went from
near total exclusion from public life
to being able to work and study in mixed
schools today
now these gains are hanging in the
balance
very recently we have reports that
districts that have been taken over by
the taliban
they have already imposed restrictions
on
women on media for instance women
are in in tahar reportedly not allowed
to leave the house without a male
chaperone clinics have been closed
there's also
reports of media blackout this is
happening
despite the taliban's promises that the
public has
nothing to fear and the situation could
intensify the group has already made
significant territorial gains in the
past months
afghan forces are struggling to hold
them off
now our people thinking if govern our
government cannot to control
this situation maybe the civil war will
be stored so that's the main problem why
people
trying to go abroad
those who couldn't afford a visa are
seeking to leave illegally
many of them are young people
they're about to cross the border to
iran before embarking on further
journeys
hoping to secure a better future